hit record here
and we're gonna see if they're done
doing
lawn activities outside
it kind of seems like they are so
oh no bam bam
thank you ma'am
always say thank you to mams they're
probably doing more than you even know
the perfect energy to start a video with
let's do it hi my name is grace i'll be
didn't know now you know your life is
different now we're cooking today that's
right you've probably already guessed it
because you're a genius and do not let
anyone
dull your shine i don't know how you let
someone get close enough to you to even
w everyone is at a few arms distance
from me i'm going to be real with you
guys for the first time everything up
into this point has been oh such a sweet
little charming lie i am experiencing
that time of the month where my body
decides to go look what i can do and i
go i i know
it's a curious time i don't know why
it's called menstruate and not
demonstrate because i feel like i have a
demon in my body demon demon there's
evil inside of me right now happening
and the only way to soothe it is to give
it what it needs and right now it needs
food all of it any of it everything all
at once i haven't seen that movie yet
but i assume it's about a woman pmsing
with free range
to a fully stocked kitchen we are making
a hello fresh meal today everybody and
today in line with this curious body
feeling we are
exploring our curiosity so i'm looking
at the hello fresh recipes that i had on
deck the one that spoke most to my i
would say heart but i'm going to say um
vagina instead is meatloaf all a mom
cozy delicious gravy covered meatloaf
and i know that i've made this before
which is why i got curious about how i
could make this again but differently
and then i realized another recipe that
i had on deck was citrus pork taco so i
got inspired and when i get inspired
watch out i thought okay what if we make
meatloaf follow mom oh we make meatloaf
tacos
because yeah you can follow the
hellofresh recipes as is which i think
i've proven is possible but i'm gonna
get a little chaotic with it chaotic
good with it basically the only thing
i'm borrowing from the citrus pork tacos
are the tortillas i'm going to instead
of making these potato wedges that it
comes with i'm going to make mashed
potatoes and the mashed potatoes are
like guacamole and then i'll put the
meatloaf in the tortillas with the
mashed potatoes and the green beans and
then the gravy goes on top like a taco
sauce and then we're gonna eat it and
give the demon what it wants how's that
sound in theory really great future me
you know you did your best you tried you
had a great idea and right now you're so
confident and excited and so we
appreciate you no matter what happens
obviously before we get into this
absolute frankenstein uh meal situation
we got some points to talk about
hellofresh recipes feature produce that
goes from the farm to your front door in
under a week so their spring menu
features the freshest flavors and their
step-by-step recipes save you so much
time in the kitchen so you don't have to
be here all day you can go outside if
you're
a person
that enjoys going outside and if you are
prove it you're sitting here watching
this video right now hello fresh offers
veggie pescetarian and fit and wholesome
recipes so you can stick to whatever
you know health goals or dietary i don't
want to say restrictions successes
you have accomplished for yourself
oh sorry i just got
very excited about this one hellofresh
is the first carbon neutral meal kit
company nearly all of their packaging is
recyclable you can cut down on your food
waste by 25
as compared to grocery store shopping
all right we've pointed to some talks
let's get into cooking this absolutely
wonderful meal and manifesting goodness
right now as always all the ingredients
for each recipe come in this handy dandy
brown paper bag which contains no eggs
which is right it doesn't contain eggs
hello hello everyone hello warm hug
don't forget to hug your friends and
this doubles has a garbage bag god i
love trash we need to preheat our oven
to 425 degrees we're gonna wash and dry
all of our produce oh how was that
shower i took one earlier it was fine so
in this recipe it says we're gonna cut
the potatoes into wedges but nah i'm
gonna basically cut them into little
pieces and put them in a pot to make
mashed potatoes let's do that first
again i have high hopes i'm exploring my
creativity today goose is left for the
room it's always good to have a creature
nearby that really humbles you makes you
question constantly what the hell you're
doing all right we're gonna fill that
with some water throw some salt in there
and then get them boiling now we are
going to half and peel the shallot this
is a metaphor for meeting new people
gotta really peel it back to get to know
them
against their will great one half on the
side of a grater this is precarious your
fingertips really trust your brain this
is pretty great huh
oh they're getting to my eyeballs
usually they don't get my eyeballs like
that but today you know what everything
is a little bit more vulnerable and
sensitive than it normally is whoa you
guys really got my eyes on that one and
now you gotta deal with this other half
oh you guys are great i thought you guys
were cool mince the remaining shallots
mince from a dinstance peel and mince
the garlic
everyone did great
of my vagina
saying move quicker now we're gonna
roughly chop our parsley i hope you like
it rough i don't like talking dirty to
food is that rough enough for you
the next step says we're gonna put the
potatoes in the oven which we're not
doing so we're gonna move on to step
three in this bowl with the already
grated shallot which i don't trust we're
going to add beef garlic panko half the
parsley salt and pepper where's the beef
can you beef leaf that i had already had
this defrosted would you like to become
a meatloaf and then a taco ah thank god
because that is what's happening today
good luck with those shallots they'll
get you i'm gonna wash my hands just
because you know raw beef human hands
garlic panko ah snowstorm mosaic it's
it's panko half of the parsley salt and
pepper we're gonna gently combine all
this and then form them into two little
tiny meatloafs two little
tiny footballs for toddlers don't let
them play with the raw beef or do i
don't know what the new parenting trend
is something very nice about this and
something very horrifying about it those
are also my thoughts on social media if
you are interested so we're gonna put
these on our baking sheet which hello
she got a brand new baking sheet that's
the sign of being an adult is when you
throw away that thing that looks like
it's been saved from a house fire and
you buy yourself a new one these get
formed into two toddler size football
yeah our potatoes are boiling that's
good we're gonna let them do that for a
bit now we're gonna brush the tops of
these with ketchup half the ketchup half
i have a brush
i guess i'm a cooking person now this
goes in the oven for five minutes after
five minutes we're gonna add our green
beans to that baking sheet with a
drizzle of olive oil and salt and pepper
and then we're going to put everything
back in for another 12 to 15 minutes
hello i'd like to get to know you knock
knock
you have a delivery oh psych it's me i'm
gonna cook you olive oil and some salt
and pepper we'll add this to the stuff
and the other things and then the next
step will happen i think i've gotten
really good at cooking or incredible at
living in my own delusion hard to tell
okay it's been five minutes time to take
the tiny footballs out add the green
beans and put them back in for 12 to 15
minutes
everyone chill and then you guys go on
sizzle sizzle what is this fajitas at a
chili's no it's just meatloaf tacos i
had a mentally well person's house all
right so now what the hell is going on
okay this is the part that we haven't
really planned for but we're just gonna
keep it going now we're going to work on
our meatloaf gravy this pan here we're
going to add half a tablespoon of butter
we're going to add our minced shallot
we're gonna cook three to four minutes
you gotta get the paper off the butter
that's a pro tip i add a little bit more
because who doesn't love butter demons
no the demons love the butter i hear you
boom mint shallot and that goes for
three to four minutes this is cooking
this is what cooking looks like a lot
going on at once let me check on our
potatoes i'm not doing that per recipe
so that's per gracie i'm gonna let them
go for a little bit longer we'll go back
to our shallots also
how long has it been in the
the next step in the gravy is that we're
gonna sprinkle it with flour who doesn't
love to be sprinkled with flour
try it once to someone and you'll find
out almost immediately if they like it
or not okay sprinkle with flour
oh
do you guys like that you have to whisk
vigorously vigorously then we stir in
the stock concentrate and then the water
whoa
oh my gosh look at that and then we cook
until thickened and saucy three to four
minutes wow that already looks like
gravy that's a freaking magic trick what
would be a magic trick is if i
remembered how long that
oven has been there and when that's done
we basically just put in the remaining
parsley and some salt and pepper and
gravy's done okay so what's up next the
mashed potatoes basically in my mashed
potatoes i just throw in a ton of butter
a little bit of milk salt pepper maybe
some sour cream if i have some that
isn't expired maybe some cream cheese if
i have some that isn't expired it's just
you know whatever you want drain our
potatoes hello would you like to hear
about my school program they're
thoroughly drained potatoes go back in
the pan then we're gonna add our butter
and then our milk why we have milk and
literally nothing else i'm not totally
sure salt pepper yes do we have any sour
cream it seems we do not what do we have
cream cheese i found garden vegetable
cream cheese in my fridge which seems to
be good let's see oh it's fine it's fine
i'm gonna add some garden vegetable
cream cheese because
i
can't be stopped and then watch this
[Music]
she bought a potato masher
[Music]
that's some leveling up we got mashed
potatoes damn we got mashed potatoes
we're supposed to add salt pepper and
parsley to the gravy make sure one more
time that the mashed potatoes are not
poisonous that's what a good chef does
not poisonous i'm basically just gonna
take the tortillas i think i'm gonna put
them just in a microwave and warm them
up let's get ready for the oven stuff to
come out of the oven that was my
impression if i was your ob gyn
delivering your baby okay i think it's
time for the stuff in the oven to come
out
and then goes our gravy which full
disclosure i forgot i left the heat on
for the gravy so it got a little thick
but that's okay it's like a chunky salsa
now
all right okay here we go here we go
hold on
[Music]
yeah i know yeah i know yeah i know yeah
this is how they look in their profile
picture and then this is how they show
up and you're like
so you also are going through
a major life crisis it seems
i can respect that okay before i even
try this i have to make sure you guys
are taken care of if you are at all
interested in trying hellofresh guess
what you can all you do is go to
hellofresh.com use the code hellbig16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts one more time go to hellofresh.com
use the code hellbig16 for up to 16 free
meals and three
surprise gifts i can't process all of it
i am gonna process this in my mouth
right now you are great in theory how
are you in practice hello friend
and my mom
one more holy [ __ ]
this is future christ
giving a high five the previous grace he
was just trying to root her on and she
thanks for for all the confidence
because
she did it oh my god this is so this is
so good you don't have to get any
utensils dirty oh my gosh this is so
good i'm sorry okay i'm not sorry what
am i sorry for i'm so not sorry for this
wow that's so good
got you wow you might hate this i
[ __ ] love this if you're also at a
curious time of the month or if you're
like really high or like really drunk or
like really a baby
i think you'll really like this i'm
usually one of those four things at any
day of the month good job good job this
is probably a not new thing and that's
fine it's new to me and i'm having a
great time with it thank you for
watching this video do with it whatever
you please whether that's the thumbs or
the subs or the comments or the
just walking away from it i respect all
of it oh i have to i have i don't know
i'm in this handy dandy brown paper bag
which contains no
eggs which is right it doesn't contain
eggs
but apparently you do